-Welcome, everybody,
welcome to The Tonight Show.
Thank you for being here.
Thank you for watching at home.
We had a great show.
Well, guys, today in England,
the world's biggest leaders
got together
for the start
of the G7 Summit.
Yeah, it's a meeting
of leaders from the U.S.,
U.K., Canada, France, Germany,
Italy, and Japan.
It's basically Epcot
without the day drinking.
This is the first in person G7
in nearly two years.
And like everyone else,
had an in-person meeting.
They're all thinking
this could have been a Zoom,
it could have been a Zoom.
In addition to the G7 members,
India, Australia,
and South Korea were invited
as guest countries.
And if they do well,
they get a spot
on the G7 spinoff
series G7 Summit Island.
[ Laughter ]
And like they do every year,
all the G7 leaders got together
for a family photo.
Take a look at this.
Yeah.
It looks like
a choose your player,
part of a law firm video game.
They had fun on the beach.
And Joe Biden asked everyone
to recreate
the volleyball
scene from "Top Gun."
You're like, I don't get this.
I read that during the summit,
all G7 leaders
are staying at this castle.
Apparently, the world economy
is in such bad shape,
they all have to share an Airbnb
is you have seven world leaders
all living
in the same house
while Vladimir Putin
watches from home
like it's an episode
of "Big Brother."
[ As Putin ]
This is my favorite show.
[ Normal voice ] Get this,
Ahead of Biden's meeting
next week with Putin,
former President Trump
decided to put out a statement
and it said, good luck to Biden
in dealing with President Putin.
Don't fall asleep
during the meeting
and please give him
my warmest regards.
Trump's still banned on Facebook
and Twitter,
so he issued that statement
by yelling at
a Wendy's drive through.
That's right, Trump had
to go through Biden
because, you know, Putin didn't
give him his real phone number.
[ As Putin] Sure Donald, yes,
it's a write this down,
1-800-588-2300
Empire Today.
[ Laughter ]
[ Normal voice ]
Well, this is huge.
The National Geographic Society
has just announced
a new fifth ocean.
It's the body of water
surrounding Antarctica,
and it's called
the Southern Ocean.
So now there's the Atlantic,
Pacific, Indian, Arctic,
and Southern.
It's such big news inspired me
to write a tiny song about it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪ Just a couple of seconds
of the show I'm hosting ♪
♪ To give a shout out
to the brand new ocean ♪
♪ Congratulations
on your promotion ♪
♪ The penguins and the fish you
got a brand new ocean ♪
♪ Ocean Mom and dad filled
with proud emotion ♪
♪ The big blue baby
is a brand new ocean ♪
♪ I wouldn't say the car,
but didn't know the postage ♪
♪ Or the address
for the brand new ocean ♪
♪ Watching all your waves
kind of like hypnosis ♪
♪ Going to need a Dramamine
on the brand new ocean ♪
♪ Protecting you from plastic
is my new devotion ♪
♪ Going to use the metal straw
in the brand new ocean ♪
♪ Even though it's cold,
put on your suntan lotion ♪
♪ Before you swim
in the brand new ocean ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
Moving on.
Hey, some entertainment news
last night was
the series finale of "Keeping Up
with the Kardashians."
Yeah, it's hard to say
goodbye watching people
stand around their kitchen,
looking at their phones.
It felt like watching
our own family.
The show led to nine spinoffs.
Kris Jenner is basically
the Vin Diesel of reality TV.
Well, listen to this.
I just saw that Netflix
just launched an online store
that sells show
branded merchandise.
But this is annoying if an item
sits in your cart for too long,
a message that says,
"Are you still shopping?"
Just a thought.
So if you're watching Netflix
and wearing it, it might be time
to get out of the house.
And finally, a lobster diver
in Cape Cod
is okay after being swallowed
and then spit out
by a humpback whale.
The good news is he's okay.
The bad news is he's being sued
for copyright infringement
by the Bible.
We have a great show.
Give it up for The Roots.
-♪ Drop a beat
and send the boat, yeah ♪
♪ We're going to
the brand new ocean ♪
♪ Drop a beat
and send the boat, yeah ♪
♪ We're going to
the brand new ocean ♪
♪ Drop a beat
and send the boat, yeah ♪
♪ We're going to
the brand new ocean ♪
-Thank you very much, everybody.
Be sure to tune
in all next week.
We have some great shows
coming up.
Ethan Hawke will be here,
Salma Hayek.
Helen Mirren and Dr. Anthony
Fauci will all be joining us.
Plus, we have music in studio
from Coldplay.
Coldplay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
But first, what a show
we have for you tonight.
She stars in "WandaVision."
Man, she crushed it.
It's on Disney+
Kathryn Hahn is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She helped us out
with our FallonVision, too.
We're gonna talk about
"WandaVision"
and we when we did our
FallonVision she was awesome.
And joining us in studio,
he's the director of the new
film "In The Heights."
Go see this.
I can't wait.
I can't wait for you
all to see it.
It is so -- I mean,
I had nothing to do with it.
I just loved it so much.
Jon M. Chu is here
great director.
Go to a theater. Stay safe.
They'll figure it out.
You have to
go see this movie.
It is unbelievable.
It is one of the most
enjoyable things I've seen ever.
It's fantastically done.
You just saw it, Quest?
-Last night.
-Were you at the --?
-I went to the, the...
-Tribeca thing?
-No, no, the the
"In the Heights."
-Oh, the Washington Heights
premiere.
-Yes.
The Washington Heights one.
-They premiered it
in Washington.
You were at that one?
-Yes.
-Oh, my gosh.
That's that's double
the excitement for me.
-It was major.
-W-Was it emotional.
What was it?
-The audience danced
and clapped and cried and yeah.
-It's it's
such a good film.
Well done. Also, we got
great music tonight.
His new album,
"Hall of Fame" is out now
performing his number one song,
"RAPSTAR" Polo G is here.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Plus, we have an all new
"Thank You Notes later
in the show.
[ Beat boxes ]
♪ In the brand new ocean ♪
That's a good jam.
-That's like a Smucker's man.
It's not that good of a jam.
-That's one if John,
John M. Chu
directed "Brand New Ocean"?
Maybe a musical about
discovering a new ocean.
I should put him on the spot?
on the show.
Guests like it, right?
-Guests love that.
People love to be
put on the spot.
-They do?
-They love it.
They love to feel uncomfortable.
Then they go, "I guess."
And then you take it as a yes,
people love it.
-Thank you.
You always give me
the best advice.
-I'm looking out for you.
-Guys, before we go on,
I got to take a moment
to mention
some of our sponsors
for tonight's show.
They always don't sometimes
fit in commercial breaks,
and we want to make sure
we get to all of them.
So it's time for
tonight's show sponsors.
Here we go.
-♪ Tonight Show ♪
♪ Sponsors ♪
♪ Tonight Show Sponsors ♪
-Our first sponsor, Apple --
you buy it because it's easier
than not buying it.
Vitamin Water -- yeah, uh,
it's good for you. Sure.
Marshalls -- sorry, a pack of
wolves just ran through here.
Lids -- buy a hat from the
quarterback
of your old high school.
Chipotle -- we keep trying
to fix whatever is wrong.
Dyson -- it's our pleasure
to make you second guess
how much a vacuum should cost.
Auntie Anne's --
Wanna ruin your flight?
How's about you scarfed down
30 pretzel nuggs
with nacho cheese sauce
and a tub of pink lemonade.
Brita -- Yeahhh. Your water
is totally clean now.
Long John Silvers --
We can't believe
we're still here either.
Are we?
And finally,
Starbucks -- Don't talk to us
till we've had our us.
That's all for
Tonight Show Sponsors.